[Applaus]
riesenjubel im moment hier im atrium des
willy-brandt-hauses für olaf scholz und
wir werden auch beim ist natürlich die
beiden parteivorsitzenden
und olaf scholz hat auch seine frau
mitmachen britta ernst jetzt wird hier
urlaub skandiert wird ganz spannend sein
was wir hier gleich sagen wird vor den
wahlen schwer zu schätzen 300 leute
vielleicht die es ins atrium hinein
geschafft haben es ist ja ein
limitiertes jeder der mit der spd heute
diesem wahlabend begehen will kann auch
ins willy-brandt-haus hinein sondern die
allermeisten müssen draußen bleiben im
außenbereich und sie hat zu diesen
außenbereich mussten vielen
interessenten abgesagt werden jetzt
großer jubel obwohl wir ja nach wie vor
nicht wirklich wissen wie diese wahl
ausbildung gegangen es das steht ja noch
einiges offen und einige zahlen sind
noch unklar und ob die spd tatsächlich
als erste partei über die ziellinie
gehen wird ist noch nicht entschieden
und insofern wird es spannend sein
obwohl es ja auch schon reagiert auf
äußerungen von armin laschet vor wenigen
minuten
wollte mich so viele hier zu sehen und
natürlich freue ich mich über das
wahlergebnis dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes gewählt haben sie
haben entschieden dass die
sozialdemokratische partei bei allen
wolken nach oben geht und das ist ein
großer erfolg
[Applaus]
das wird ein langer wahlabend das ist
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger ihr
kreuz bei der spd gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es einen wechsel in der
regierung gibt und auch weil sie wollen
dass der nächste kanzler des landes und
auch stolz
wir haben geworben dafür dass sind
dieser gesellschaft wieder mehr respekt
herrscht wir haben uns dafür eingesetzt
dass es gelingt die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes
voranzubringen und wir haben uns dafür
eingesetzt dass es klappt den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten drei große ziele die jetzt
am beginn der 20er jahre von unserem
land zu bewältigen sind ziele für die
wir uns miteinander eingesetzt haben
aber dass das möglich ist dass die
umfrage sich so gut entwickelt haben
dass wir jetzt die ersten hochrechnungen
haben die zeigen die spd kriegt viel
unterstützung von den bürgern und
bürgern das ist ein auftrag dafür zu
sorgen dass all das was in dieser wahl
besprochen wurde und was wir
vorgeschlagen haben auch umgesetzt wird
und wir uns politisch dafür stark machen
[Applaus]
aber
an dieser stelle möchte ich auch danke
sagen
danke den bürgern und bürgern die uns
und mir die stimme gegeben haben damit
ein solches wahlergebnis möglich wird
aber ich sage auch als einer von 400.000
mitgliedern der spd danke an all
diejenigen die jeden tag dafür geworben
haben dass das auch jetzt möglich wird
[Applaus]
wir sind eine pragmatische partei die
weiß wie man regiert wir sind eine
zuversichtliche partei die dafür sich
einsetzen will dass wir eine bessere
zukunft in deutschland haben aber wir
haben auch gezeigt dass wir das
mitbringen was man braucht wenn man ein
land regieren will nämlich
geschlossenheit die von allen getragen
ist und dass das so war dafür möchte ich
mich auch bedanken
[Applaus]